[Music]
bloodborne Dark Souls Demon Souls these
game titles will likely have an effect
on you whether that's positive or
negative
whether that's joy frustration or you're
already trying to find another video to
watch instead of this one
there's something about from software
games that attracts players who like to
be challenged players who want heavy RPG
elements and scares away pretty much
everyone else
well Sakura is here to bridge the gap
between both mentalities and transforms
the souls games into an action-adventure
narrative focus which is both open to
new players but holds enough depth to
keep the traditional players happy
here's 16 things you should know about
Sakura shadows die twice let's start
with the mysterious story in a 16th
century war-torn Japan after a bloodbath
of war we see a young boy scavenging for
a way to survived after his family were
most likely killed in this great battle
so we already know one thing they're
going down the orphan route the lone
wolf a great way to get us to instantly
care about this character and his story
a battle-hardened warrior takes the
often under his wing and 20 or so years
go by he's grown up and he's become a
loveable katana wielding death bringing
shinobi just like his mother likely
wanted our character loses everything
the moment we take control our mentor is
gone the person we are tasked with
protecting has been captured by a rival
faction oh and our arm is removed in
battle replaced with this prosthetic
seen in the trailers which gives those
abilities which are at the core of the
game also we can't die so let's leave
the story there basically we're a badass
unkillable shinobi often after vengeance
sounds great to me it may look the
Sakura is set in realism the rebuilding
of 16th century Japan the reworking of
an ancient battle but keep in mind we
have a magical arm will be fighting
fantastical beasts oversized humans and
if you've played any of From Software's
back-catalogue
you know to expect the unexpected
realism is a starting point fantasy is
the destination we already know that we
can't die and that's thanks to something
called dragon blood but we'll get to
that in a little while the first thing I
really want to talk about is combat one
of the major drawing points to all the
famous from software
titles is the combat system fluid
responsive unwavering in detail and most
of all demanding and devastating from
the untrained eye it looks like a hack
and slash athon like Devil May Cry
Masters so well but in this scenario
you'd be wrong to carry all values every
fight but won't bog you down in managing
stamina the one-armed wolf can move
around with glee the battles are weighed
towards locating weaknesses in your foes
and causing their posture or balance if
you prefer to break for a single moment
before ending the battle in a single
sword cinematic if I've made battles
seem basic let me reiterate the
complexity knowing when to parry to
evade to jump to counter to run away and
hide or battle to the death are all to
be mastered leading up to that deathblow
moment which by the way can only be
completed if your opponent is low on
health or their posture is broken and
yet you have the same system in place
too so you could die in a single hit if
you're not careful so let's talk about
that mythical arm we are given at the
start of the game our first ability is
the grappling hook designed to get us
around the map quickly and as a heck of
a lot of verticality to the game which
also plays a major part in stealth but
we'll get to that as you'd expect the
arm has more to offer than a one-trick
pony as items can be found undone locked
during the campaign that can be equipped
to our prosthetic by the character named
the sculptor all the shinobi attachments
can be freely changed like a loadout
before a mission or even mid-fight on
the fly for example if enemies have
shields equipped the right tool to bust
through them instantly in that respect
knowledge of enemies and more
importantly knowledge of your own tools
and skills are vital inventory
management may not be glamorous but it
does have a place in secare oh and a
note to keep us on our toes
we'll need spirit emblems to use certain
tools in our shinobi Arsenal and of
course they can run out but we'll find
them all over the world inventory
management and resource control
there are definitely elements of the
souls games in here I touched on stealth
so let's go back to that for a moment
before sukira was announced I was almost
certain tenchu stealth assassins was
about to be unveiled I admit I was a
little gutted when it wasn't but it's
here insuk arrow first you should know
that from software currently has the
rights to the tenchu series and
awesome game in which we could fight
enemies head-on but the real draw of
that game was stealthily killing off an
entire army one by one with stealth
kills sukira has this mechanic and it's
a huge part of the game originally they
thought about making sake hero an
official tenchu title but decided
against it to keep their own style
intact the stealth mechanic insuk arrow
allows the Worland wolf to use his
grapple hook to survey the area and
single out guards and other foals to
swoop down murder eyes and return to the
rafters unseen it's such a great
inclusion it almost feels like a
separate game which breaks up the
demanding swordplay perfectly in the
back of our minds we know that if we've
been spotted we're gonna have to fight
our way out of this and with a potential
single sword swing ending the fight it's
quite nerve-wracking so channel your
inner Ricky Maru and stealth ninja at
every opportunity and here's a kicker
you may hear something said by one of
the characters you can eavesdrop in the
game in one scenario we snuck up on
these two characters who were talking
about their boss who has a fear of fire
so off we trotted to grab some fire to
make that encounter much easier knowing
your enemy is half the battle killing
them is the other half of course here's
a cool mechanic to know about memories
of the past it's possible to travel back
three years in time thanks to a young
Lords bail charm which instantly takes
the one-armed wolf to a previous point
in the story at a time when we didn't
have this arm prosthetic which is going
to cause some issues we're told
completing memories impacts the present
day maybe if you're getting your ass
handed to you it could be worth
traveling back in time to upskill and
potentially open up a hidden room for
use back in present day my brain hurts
thinking about that it's like shinobi
ception
from software is renowned for making
in-depth RPGs with thousands of ways to
complete every task or battle not this
time Sakura has a fixed focus on a
single character we won't be building
our own we won't dictate the abilities
in the same way as blood-borne or Dark
Souls those that have played the
previous from software titles will know
how frustrating it could be to pick up
an item which has no bearing on the
character you've built
I found that the rush of looting was
quickly washed away into a grind for
items made for your exact character
build yeah I know I'm dumbing this down
probably too much but hopefully that
will hit those gamers on the fence
although challenging frustrating and
demanding Sakura will be it won't be so
fast that most of the content is locked
behind other character builds we all
play as the same wolf experience his
story and upgrade and evolve in a
similar way for die-hard Souls born fans
that may be discouraging but the
fromsoftware team has added so much to
make Sicario much more than its
predecessors this is a unique beast so
let's talk about upgrades although it's
not RPG focused there are some RPG light
elements Sicario is packed with upgrades
they are broken into three sections
combat shinobi martial arts and latent
skills each of these areas unlock skills
both passively and actively early
shinobi skills include a world wind
sword attack great for panicking when
you're over faced with enemies but other
skills can unlock counters to enemy
thrusts are allow you to carry more of a
specific item such as the sacred spirit
emblems which we'll be looking for
throughout the entire game we gain XP
from killing enemies usually through
quickly offering multiple enemies
without dying filling up our XP bar will
give us a skill point which goes towards
new skills in those upgrade paths we can
also exchange collectible items for
health upgrades posture improvements or
even attack power later in the game
these are found in the world or on
defeated enemies killing some specific
enemies in particular can fast-track the
wolf with certain skills we can also
purchase skills from merchants and other
vendors in the world who will ask for
strange items in return protip if you
see any cap swimming around grab their
scales resurrection is another key
mechanic in secure shadows die twice
because one thing that will happen often
is death
yeah hundreds of deaths are expected
during a typical playthrough in previous
Souls games we could find our point of
death
tracking down a puddle of blood and
grabbing our lost progression in Sakura
death will see us instantly lose half of
our skill points progression and half of
any cash we're carrying and simply puts
everything lost is gone for good tough
break but it is possible to uncover the
grey
of God's to minimize the loss upon death
but dying should feel like a step
backwards but that's where resurrections
come in should you fall in battle
resurrection will allow the one-armed
wolf to pop back up into battle this is
more than a second chance timing this
right can give an opening to end a boss
battle it can be used to sneak past
enemies it can be used to put any dead
until the very last second and then
quickly grapple to the roof ultimately
our death can be used tactically here's
something to know about death dragon
rocks will learn about Dragon Rock
during the game but what we know right
now is that each death we suffer will
impact living beings in the world they
will fall ill with dragon rocks hoping
your loved ones will be okay all the way
to the end of the game is all well and
good but the first time they cough is a
sign that they may be dying soon and
it's all your fault it's all because of
you this will likely feed into multiple
endings insuk arrow as if you like me we
have to save everyone to be the hero of
this story demands so I suppose that
really should be a standalone point
multiple endings confirms this will not
be a one playthrough wonder for anyone
invested in narrative the relationships
made throughout the game are impacted on
by many things the aforementioned dragon
rots will be pivotal to the game but
director has said all endings are rooted
in the story so it's safe to say there
won't be a random ending which makes no
sense kinda like the dog ending in
Silent Hill as the game is so vast and
death can take us all the way back to
the starting location it's important to
keep an eye out for these sculptors
idols dotted around the world these are
in fact the fast travel system of Sakura
in addition to old-fashioned checkpoints
resting here can restore attributes but
it will also heal enemies you've been
battling the idols can also be used to
upgrade on the fly so if you desperately
need a health boost before a
particularly tricky fight the idol is
your friend as an ending point something
which won't impact the game hugely but
something I love to see in dynamic video
games ai fighting AI foes fighting foes
it's possible to witness your enemies
going at it without you interfering
whatsoever it's even possible to
persuade a foe to follow you directly
leading them into another factions camp
honestly so many hours of fun to be
hugged with this I wonder if we can get
help during a boss fight I know what
I'll be doing de water just in case it
wasn't hinted at enough sukira shadows
die twice is a single-player game there
is no PvP portion as in other from
software titles it's possible something
could be added later in the game cycle
maybe introducing the invasion mechanic
from Dark Souls which allows players to
jump into someone else's game and either
help or hinder them time will tell
but on day one this is solely a
single-player game and finally last few
pieces of housekeeping sukira shadows
die twice releases on March 22nd
worldwide on ps4 Xbox one and Windows PC
there's a collector's edition available
right now which includes the full game
limited edition steelbook 7 inches of
the one-armed wolf in Statue form a map
3 Sengoku coins a digital version of the
soundtrack and a gorgeous art book I
can't resist art books so there we have
it secured all shadows die twice what do
you think are you going to try it from
what I've seen sukira is closer to the
modern God of War game than Dark Souls
which will sound horrible to some people
but brilliant to others I can't wait to
eavesdrop on enemies and find boss
weaknesses and have two factions
fighting each other while I watch from a
rooftop with popcorn in hand I admit
I've never finished a Dark Souls game so
I'm hyped for something less demanding
with an added focus on narrative and
mythical qualities of feudal Japan I'm
truly interested in your opinions here
throw a comment below I'll come talk to
me on Twitter
I'm Adam grenade over there anyway I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]